going on multiple live streams, multiple live streams, saying
how you want to legitimately touch kids, legitimately cuddle
with kids. Uh, that's probably more of a harmful joke than a
one-off obvious obvious joke. Uh, you know, >> but this
is obviously far worse, right? Food Chops is watching Destiny's
minor son debate Drew Pavlau, and Destiny raids into Food Chops
while she's doing >> Did he know? Did he know that his
son was being watched or did he know that this person's a I'm
guessing that he knew both, but he'd probably deny both. He signed
an affidavit that says, "I sent it to this person." Then, "Hey,
lol. I know I violated your trust in the worst way ever, but
here's some money. Have fun." That makes no sense, right? So,
he's just lying. He's like transparently lying.
I saw that there's some content going on there. What's going
on there? What was happening there? What's going on there? What's
happening there? I'm a thousand% not going to tolerate that
>> cuz listen
there is a what was it? I think Dickers did showed some clips.
Okay, looks like moral is going to go through some of the dickers
clips right now. All right, but whatever. Whatever. Leaks Mau
DMs calls moral bad faith for saying that he justifies the docks
of random people who associate with others who dislike Destiny.
Malo believes food shops is a spineless hypocrite with zero principles
or morals. Zero. Wow. >> Zero. Okay, let's take a look.
>> Is this before or after you wrap your arms around that
toy? This is referencing a [__] edgy joke. >> Action
Man stream from tonight. What's What's the deal with the Action
Man stream from tonight? Not a drug dealer. >> Referencing
an edgy joke. That's referencing an edgy joke. Should we see
this edgy joke?
>> This is the They're referencing. >> Okay, one
second. I've got some food. >> Give me a second. the most
feminine of the most feminine.
>> I'm only into the most feminine of the most feminine.
>> That's what I'm saying. >> I need to I need to
have a little girl to wrap myself around. >> I need to
have a little girl to wrap myself around. >> Christ, dude.
>> Oh, like you're like
big spoon is what you're saying. Oh, I get you. >> I need
to have like a 12-year-old. >> I need to have a 12year-old.
Oh. Oh, okay. >> Bro, isn't it crazy? It's crazy that Moral
gets to play the high ground on the uh
>> on the weird comments about miners hill. Okay, he gets
to play the high ground >> So that's the joke. That's the
joke you're referencing right there. So let's play this again.
>> Is this before or after you wrap your arms around that
toilet is referencing a edgy joke. >> Now I want to make
it perfectly clear. food shops in my debate with them. We spent
a large portion of that debate arguing on whether edgy jokes
were fine and if it was okay to say edgy jokes.
>> I don't really want to get into the tier listing of
edgy jokes so much, okay? I don't really want to get into tier
listing of the edgy jokes so much. I don't really want to say,
you know, one's worse than the other. However, I
Whoops. Anybody who's in this person's chats, anybody who does
like does content with this person, they need to all be on a
list. By the way,
I don't know if you guys realize this. Didn't Connor crash the
[__] out on like Chud
for for platforming food shops? Am I crazy on that? Could I find
that somewhere?
Someone tell me if I'm wrong on that. I could have sworn Connor
counter points went and crashed the [__] out for
platforming this person.
Yeah, you Destiny a message and was like, "Hey, uh, you collabing
with this guy?" Oh, sorry. This woman, you absolutely did. Okay,
just, you know, as long as we're countering, as long as we're
counting, we can count the the principles counterpoints is just
throwing away throwing in the trash. Although, to be fair on
this one, he kind of already threw it in the trash cuz Vosch
absolutely had the lolly horse thing, right? And counter counterpoints
defended clapping with Bosch. But this is obviously far worse,
right? Obviously far worse. just right now. >> I think
it's pretty fair to say going on multiple live streams, multiple
live streams, saying how you want to legitimately touch kids,
legitimately cuddle with kids. Uh, that's probably more of a
harmful joke than a one-off obvious obvious joke. Uh, you know,
Max Striker donation, but that's just me. That's just me. And
then not just that, let's listen to some of the banger lines
in this little song. Shout out to Jazz Dog. Shout out to Jazz
Dog. Let's listen to some of the lines in this song. Let's listen
to some of the stuff that's said in this song. >> Hold
on. Let's Let's see. >> Are you attracted to children?
>> Are you attracted to children? Yeah. >> Are you
attracted to the lolly? >> Um,
yes. Wait, but I but I wait but
you jerk off.
>> Oh my god, my friend. I just passed. You see count?
>> you jerked off too low. >> But I but
I said it's I said I probably ped Jason. >> Rowdy, stop
being so clippable here. That's true a little bit. I just want
to say I don't know who in the the cabal that we're running has
the like
has like the weird guju doll that's making all of the degenerate
predators like go to the same place
but they're like all joining up on the same team recently. I
don't know why that is. I don't know what that is. 2 hours 258
time stamp for action man. Okay. I don't even know what that's
about. We might check it out later. Okay. We're doing a little
morale content right now. >> Lollipop is pretty pedo adjacent.
This absolutely pedo Jason >> the uh the food chops person
is somebody who like does a bunch of content on this stream and
is incapable of conscience conscious thought. Okay, I offered
them a debate on the doxing thing. They just totally turned it
down. No, no, no, no, no, no way. Apparently,
very sad.
Click on this. Okay, Porter Beller, this is the last time I'm
trusting you. Okay, if this is some anti-Jewish [__]
I'm out. I feel like yeah, there's some people >> this
is some better talk about it and I think some people come at
it from more of a free speech perspective and that does go to
like the consumption side and you know there's a line there and
I don't really like that necessarily but I think the vast majority
of perspective and views on this um across like the country I
mean possession of it is illegal in the UK it's fedally illegal
I believe in the US I just think that society generally is so
heavily weighted against it I just don't really feel the need
to like go super hard to reinforce that considering the amount
of other things that I see sliding food shops but I see them
trying to start the normalization trend talking about how they
self treated their POCD >> how's that going for them remind
me how what's the public response been to that >> overwhelmingly
negative >> but you want me to reinforce that further and
say oh guys just remind >> you don't have to I think it's
perfectly fine if you say don't consume it but production of
it as long as you don't get aroused by a crime without a victim
I think it's insufficient for me and I do think that if you took
a moral fraud position such as myself you would lose a to viewers
and that's what I said and I stand by it. >> Wow. Wow.
Wow.
Wow. But now now I wonder if Connor's positions have changed
at all there. Well, it it's he's basically run to the aerodite
thing, right? Where Connor says he has these principles, but
he's not willing to do anything to act on them, right? He's never
willing to do anything to enforce his principles. They're like
hypothetical principles. Like in a in a in a world where, you
know, I wasn't I wasn't a shameless grifter. These principles
could matter
Hypothetically, it's very interesting. This is your red bill
king. We actually might have to watch this later. Apparently,
it's a good video. Okay, it's a it's a Myron Gaines video. Abba
impreach Myron Gains video. I might have to check that out in
a little bit. Okay, let's get back to the morale content. Let's
see. He watches this. I wonder if he moves forward at some point
here.
yes, I jerk off to Lycon. Yes, Lolly. >> What does that
even mean? Production of Lolli is fine if you don't get aroused
by it. as in like you don't care that people make lolly stuff,
right?
You don't necessarily care, but but like you don't want getting
off to it or something because it might reinforce some loop.
It's like a free speech issue. That's the free speech thing,
right? Where you don't care if it's produced. You don't need
laws against it. That kind of thing. I think Connor saying that's
in insufficient for him. >> Con is and yes, I consider
lollycon to be drawn child. So, Food Shops right here is admitting
they consider themselves to jerk off to illustrated child illustrated
child drawn child. Keep that in mind when we watch the rest of
this clip. >> I've made that.
>> Oh, hold on. This is Wait, you know what actually makes
this so much better? Okay, you know what makes this so much more
incredible? Okay, we got this whole food chops thing going on
right now. But also, just as a little aside,
friend of the stream, Mantis Praise, with a tweet here. Okay.
Apparently,
uh, tonight Destiny's kid was debating Drew Pavlu. Food Chops
was watching this and Destiny raided food shops. Destiny raided
into food shops, farming, Drew Pavlu, farming his son.
So he he feeds into he he literally raids into an admitted small
pe who is farming his minor child
who's being farmed by Drew Pavlau. This
>> I watched a little bit of it. Do you pull this clip?
Hold on. Do I got it here? Where's my Chud clip? >> I feel
>> Do you Did you know Connor came in like moralized to
Chud about platforming food shops? Did you get this this bit
brought >> Um I saw that a couple days ago. I didn't play
it on stream though. I know of it. I know that it exists. >> I
just think it's funny watching Conor drop another one of his
uh principles that like he's definitely not going to do anything
about this. He's just going to like >> oh that that principle
that you know my friend's totally Yeah. What can you do guys?
We got to beat Trump
at what what do you think the actual breaking point for Connor
is? I feel like this would be a fun pool to start. What do you
think Connor's actual breaking point with his Destiny guy would
be? Like if this Destiny guy
>> I don't think it's I think it's in I think it's in >> Oh
well we depending on how strict you are we might have gotten
there tonight. Did you catch this one? Hold on.
>> Oh no. Don't tell me. >> Hold on. Did you catch
this one? That food chops is watching Destiny's minor son debate
Drew Pavloo and Destiny raids into food chops while she's doing
that. >> Did he know? Did he know that his son was being
watched or did he know that this person's a I'm guessing that
he knew both, but he'd probably deny both. >> Bro,
that's rough. Jesus.
Have you seen um I know it's not new, but he's Nate's been tweeting
about it. Uh people have been DMing him like the the clip of
Destiny like sucking. It's so >> Yeah, I don't I generally
like
we try to keep off him off the topic or off topic here, you know?
out of bounds. My bad. I brought it up. No, I brought it up,
but it's like uh >> Yeah, I try not to talk about it because
like it's just Yeah. >> No, I won't bring It's my bad.
I >> No, no, no. It's like I've seen people say that or
I've seen Destiny said that, right? Destiny's complained about
that. So,
um obviously gross. Obviously, people are Yeah. >> Yeah.
No. Yeah. I think that's it's evil. It's ontologically evil.
Um,
dude, their reasoning for just some of the [__] they
said they they said in uh in in when they were reading out my
DM, they said, "Oh, I was being fair with my doxing take and
then immediately after they were saying I'm bad faith." And it's
like,
"How am I How am I both of these things? How am I both fair and
bad faith at the same time? This is so what do you mean? What
do you mean?" >> They're actually like too stupid to understand.
Like they are actually um this is like the proof that it's a
cult, right? the the whole Destiny thing is a cult is like they're
actually somewhat watching this person like like this I you have
no idea how badly watching this person speak to anybody who's
even remotely critical of them shakes my faith in like my ability
to stream. Okay, cuz like I built a platform and it's like dude
there's no way that these people would just listen to anybody
no matter how they are. But it's true. There's like are mostly
gone from me but like holy holy [__] >> I try
I I think of bits in advance. I like write down notes of like
things I think are funny to say. I try to be entertaining. I
try to be funny. I try to like put on like a semi-entertaining
live stream at least. Um, and then I see them, they literally
don't react to the content. They're just playing Borderlands
2 the entire time and they get like 300 concurrent. And I'm sitting
there with my like 50 viewers. I'm like, what what the am I doing
wrong? What am I What do I What am I doing wrong? I don't like
I try and they're just sitting there literally free booting content.
I w I tried to they made a video on Auggie or like a live stream
segment on Auggie and literally within like I I watched half
of the video I think they said five things. None of them were
related to the content. Most of it was just them listening to
it
in the first half. >> I watched Stardust do that with my
content and I was just like dude these people these people got
to go. Like these it's so crazy. like there's like actual arguments
going on, people are making points and instead of listening,
they just like don't they just talk to the chat, they'll just
like click random chat messages the whole time. And I understand
that sometimes while you're watching a stream or while you're
watching content, you get an off-topic chat message, maybe even
like three in a row. But if you're doing it for like 30 minutes
to 90 minutes and you don't comment, you comment like 10% as
much on the content as you do 90 it's like 10% content, 90% chat
or just never commenting on the content. Uh, it's so [__]
like when your comments just aren't even related. >> Like
if I find a piece Yeah. If I find a piece of content, I literally
can't just like I if there's literally nothing for me to talk
about, I just won't watch it most of the time. Like I'll just
be like, "Okay, there's I don't have anything to say. Like I
either I agree with this completely, I don't have anything to
say or or I just move on." Like I can't imag
It's literally just like um this is an example of content that
is not like fair use. They're not doing anything. It's just I'm
not going to make a fuss out of it or anything because that's
[__] and cringe, but it's just like, how does this
person have 300 concurrent? What am I doing wrong? Do I need
to be a Do I need to be more of a Do I need to do Do I need to
message a 16-year-old? Like, >> that's a joke. I would
not do that. But it's just very It's very uh It's very confusing.
I don't get it. I don't understand. Uh, >> I want to know
what shops do out of the >> I think it's just somebody
telling them that uh JTO's bad, right?
>> I think I think that's like what it is right now. Or
the Queenman thing. I think. Is that crazy? >> They just
really don't like um they really don't like Queman. I know that.
Um I don't know what their deal is with you. I think honestly
they probably just don't like you because of Destiny.
>> Yeah. Well, I mean that's they watch like all of my
content. They watch like all of it. >> Dude, they're so
much harder. You know that you like I did. I did.
>> you know, I did that on that recorded.
>> Why? What was the you like gay op you owned or something?
I'm assuming. >> No, I No, I just was like going to go
play video games. I want to go play like Civer. Did I play Civer
backpack battles? I was just like chilling. I was like going
to chill and I was like, "Oh, I'll do that off stream. I'm going
to watch this and see what they say." >> Right. And then
I was like tired. I was like, "Ep went to bed." They're like,
"Oh, do it on stream." It's like I did it in a public channel.
I literally did it a public channel explicitly so anyone could
join. >> I didn't um
I didn't watch it on stream, but I watched it. I watched a bit
of it and um they were like complaining the entire time. They're
like, "Why is Jtock not saying anything? Why is JTO not doing
anything?" And it's like, "Bro, it's a offline call. What do
you do? You expect this guy to be like constantly like I don't
know." >> I was tired. I was done my stream and so I was
like, I'm going to watch this anyway. I'll go and I'll log off
and we'll go watch it. It's another madeup dimension. It's just
very funny that it's like, well, one of us is living in a in
a one of us is living in a madeup dimension.
I I would like to talk to about her about it or I about the doxing
stuff, right? >> Dude, they literally admitted that they
would lose in a debate to you. It was so
>> I'm not even
>> Oh my god.
>> It's so mindn numbing. It's so mindn numbing. like they're
they're so they're so like openly and honestly like
I don't understand I do not understand I can't comprehend as
a viewer cuz I watch the content too. I I take part in all three
of it. I watch the content I stream and I make video essays.
I know like how it is to participate in all three of those, right?
I cannot
comprehend how a viewer could watch that when they're so openly
and honestly like just and like inconsistent
um like openly lying openly just being dishonest and then admitting
like yeah I think my position on docking doxing is so weak that
I'd lose to Jtock.
Not that you're a bad debater or anything. It's just like
what like I how can people enjoy this? How do people like this
girl? >> I don't Yeah, I don't know. >> Rhetorical
question, I guess. But yeah, I don't know. Um, I watched something.
I watched like their Lonerbox piece or something through Dickers,
right? They were watching Lonerbox. They might have even been
watching me watching Loner Box and like they literally just don't
understand the points being made by anyone. Like they actually
can't comprehend like anything being argued.
>> It's
It's not even I understand why people watch, but I actually don't
get uh I don't know. I I feel like I would have shame. I feel
like if I don't understand something, I feel shame for like watching
it and not understanding.
>> I feel like I switch topics. They don't have any of
that. There's nothing there. >> Like I'll I'll move on
to something I know and then I'll look at that other thing. Like
tonight I was going to do the Roblox stuff and I I know I have
to look some stuff up for it while I'm like doing it. So it's
like, oh, I'll save it until tomorrow. I'll save looking at it
till tomorrow. I just there's a couple hooks for it that I'm
really interested in. But um but for other for for this person,
they'll like just throw up someone else's content and like AFK
play video games and then like they'll barely hear something.
They'll like mish hear something and then they'll just go h and
they'll try to make a point. >> Yeah.
I don't know. It's very um it's very mindboggling. So what what
is the uh
what did you watch specifically? What was interesting to you
about my coverage, I guess? >> Oh, I didn't get that far
into it. I was just I just started watching it. I was just like
I don't know if you were >> I don't even know like what
you were what did you think was like the best stuff because you
went through Max's stuff and I know you went through the dicker
tweets originally.
>> Someone sent me a queen and clip >> on towards
towards the end I started watching some older stuff. Um I was
going to watch their they had two Mr. Girl callins. >> Um
it was getting late and I I'm going to go to bed soon so I just
ended stream. I'll do it like tomorrow or next time. Um, I was
going to watch that, but the mainly what I watched was their
uh why they burned the bridge with me or whatever. Then I tried
to watch their Auggie video. Uh, and then I got donated enough
money so I started watching the uh I I read through their uh
manifesto
which was epic and uh
awesome. And then I watched um
their Zonia Zonia call-in where they say they were they self-prescribed
themselves. They weren't even prescribed by a they uh they self-prescribed
themselves to jerk off to Lollcon
uh for their POCD that was not diagnosed. So they got they self
diagnosed with POCD and then self-prescribed themselves Lollcon.
And they said this on a live stream. They said this on a live
stream.
I just want to I just want to say they said that on a live stream.
And we also have We also live in a world where this tweet exists.
I should save this. Mantis is almost certainly going to take
this tweet down soon. If it's not gone yet, it'll be gone soon.
I should save this
That's wild.
>> did you ever watch, speaking of uh miners debating or
something, did you ever watch um Destiny debate Lieutenant Corbus
on on child?
>> That was an epic debate. You should you would enjoy
that. I hope you would enjoy it. It was very funny. He debates
uh he debates Lieutenant Corbus, which I believe at the time
was like 15 or 16 on the ethics of a child. >> Can't make
this stuff up, dude. I Dude. Oh, here here it is. Yeah. Anyone
who sh on him relentlessly the way he does to others is 10 out
of 10 content gigab based except I'm willing to talk to people
about my takes
right talk to anyone who wants to call in
but not quite the same let him talk to his stupid parents about
it Jesus dude yeah I actually didn't get that far into your content
I was just like oh if you want to hop on you could hop on I was
just more going to ask you like what you thought about doing
the the coverage
>> um
I mean I knew roughly Um, I knew roughly what they had done in
the past, but it's one of those things where it's like it's a
lot like Stardust where it's like I know they've done some like
but watching through it for me is just kind of like boring. Uh,
so for this
when they're literally like people who I consider to be like
internet friends, they're literally just like excusing their
doces or justifying their doces. Uh, and then they they try to
get ahead of it basically by saying like, "Well, I'm burning
the bridge with you." And it's like this is so gay. What's your
reasoning for burning the bridge? I called you a Let's look at
your past history and see if it's like justified to call you
a and then you look at their past history. Uh, and they are a
self self-prescribed POCD, self-prescribed lollycon and it's
like you're mad that I called you a It's like no, you're mad
that I like argued with you and I'm against Destiny and all this
[__] Like it's so obviously cope. You can watch it.
Like their arguments are they do the whole gay with with their
whole
doxing argument.
They don't they they try to get away from the moral argument.
They're like, "No, I wouldn't be surprised if this happened."
And it's like, "Okay, we'll talk about if it's right or wrong."
Like, I don't know. This is like not engagement, pathetic. Like,
it's like, "Well, if you go outside, I would like if you go outside
wearing a short skirt, I wouldn't be surprised if you got raped."
And it's like, "Okay, well, is it bad that they got raped? Is
it good that they got like talk about what is the moral? Like,
is it okay to do this thing?" And they don't they never touch
that. um they try to play it like really safe, but it's just
so obviously like they they don't want to uh >> they're
just int they're like incredibly different arguments and it's
like okay so everybody who's criticizes bad empanada by by that
like by what you're saying then yeah you could expect to get
doxed right
>> but but it's like um >> they would have no problem
morally decrying bad empanada for doxing right like obviously
they can see it when it's somebody else when it's somebody who's
not Destiny they would absolutely go after these people Right.
You can say it. Destiny says, "Oh, well, there's anything any
act against bad is is okay." Right? Any act against him, that's
totally fine. Do you know? Sorry. Do you know what I'm saying?
>> Um, sorry, I'm reading something on the side. I just
got sent something. Uh, repeat what you said. I apologize. >> I'm
saying that like they have no problem morally like going to the
moral argument when it's bad empanada. Like Destiny himself will
go to the moral argument on bad empanada and say anything that
happens to this guy is justified, right? This guy's like a morally
evil actor. Anything that happens to him is justified. But they
they can't apply that at all to Destiny. And it's like, okay,
well, that should just be telling to you, right? You can obviously
say that bad is bad. He's
>> but you can't say it about Destiny. Seems concerning.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I agree. I Dude, the
I feel I I just wish we had like um I said this on stream, too.
I don't know if it'll like I don't remember exactly where it
was, but like yeah, you should I I feel like doxing is one of
those things where you should have like no exceptions for it.
It doesn't matter if you're [__] doesn't matter if
you're, you know, random video game streamer. It doesn't matter
who you are. Uh, you should not be doxed. Internet vigilantism
in that form is not helpful. It doesn't do anything. Um, it does
not provide results. Like if you dox a look at EDP, EDP was outed
for being a like years ago and he's still out. He's not in jail.
He was never convicted of anything. Doxing anybody for any sort
of reason, especially for like petty internet drama, does not
do anything. It just makes you look like a you should be principally
against doxing no matter who it is. Like if someone's doing something
illegal, go to the cops. If someone's, you know, with you or
or criticizing you, respond to it or ignore it. Uh if you give
it attention, but your attention is to like escalate to an insane
degree is um is like just
um and like I feel like food shops of all people should be against
doxing considering their past. Again, absolutely no no justification
for if they're doxed. I don't think they should be doxed, but
like if anybody could justify a dox on someone, it would be food
shops given some of the insane that they've said. So, it's just
it's so confusing to me how they're um they're like justifying
it to people who are critical of Destiny, I guess. >> It's
Dude, it's um I don't know. I I feel like it's up cuz why is
Hassan's like the only big creator I've really even seen mention
it? like almost nobody else cares to talk about it. Do you see
SFO? SFO came into my Discord to watch the uh the call or whatever
and then they're talking me in food shops chat and I'm like I
literally message him. I'm like, "Hey, we could like literally
just talk about he's like, "You did a hit. You did a you say
I like shanked him or something."
Hold on, let me pull this up. >> I I used to like I used
to like short photo. Um my IRL friend actually introduced me
to him, funnily enough, but like his recent just like takes on
Yeah, bro. So, I gave a nuance take on Destiny case and got the
Jtock shank. Feels bad, man. We were pals for a
>> Wait, how'd you say that? >> He uh
uh he put it in food shops chat. I >> and sent it. Yeah.
Yeah. >> Okay. All right.
>> Yeah. I messaged it to him. I was like, "How did I shank
you?" He's like, "I gave the most milktoast take and you devoted
a whole segment to to it. Come on, man." And the segment was
calling out like the most argument he had with like uh Ellie
B on Twitter where he just looked stupid and it was me just pointing
out that he looked stupid. Oh, I don't have my old [__]
Ah, hold on.
let me see if I can find it really quickly. What's Ellie B's
handle again? Ellie B again. >> Here, I'll send you this.
I don't think he likes me. He left me on red. Um,
you can leak. I give you permission to leak these. I don't think
he wants to. He might hate me and want me dead, dude. I don't
know. >> Wait, is it not sleepy devo?
Sleepy_devo.
Oh, I'm trying to I'll leak those in just a second.
Take your time. >> Um, but I just want to go see if I can
find Oh, never mind. That's not it. Okay, hold on. Let's take
a look. Let's take a look. Yeah, yeah, yeah. This is the one
I looked at. That was funny. Got the Jtock shank. I dude I could
have called him out from like any point of view and I asked him
to come on stream and talk about it and he did not want to talk
about it. What is this little short fat otaku? Can you be the
destiny of my food shops? Lol. No, I don't want to have with
you. Not what I was getting at like want to call in smile like
that angel of things. That angle of things. I don't know why
I said angel angle of things. Maybe if there's big old dramas
I'm a part of. Dev just like kind of sits on the sideline and
then he makes like Yeah, I I realize this. I'm I'm sitting here
and I'm like, "Bro, you can just come on stream and talk about
it." Like, I'm totally fine talking about Exactly. If you want
to talk about it, I'll pull up the thing where you said I shanked
you and we can talk through it really easily. Mantis got into
a huge argument with SFO for objectifying food shops and he admitted
in that combo he was a chaser. Yeah, I I literally he could just
hop on and like talk about any of these things whenever he wants.
>> I don't know why he wouldn't. I need to find the >> Do
you leak the DMs?
>> These aren't my DMs. >> He's leaking my DMs. Oh,
he's looking at your DMs. It's tough. >> I need to be able
to find this cuz this was like so stupid. Oh, hold on.
Uh, is this the one? [__] Hold on. Give me a second.
I will find I'll find it. Give me a second, guys. Nope, that's
not it. I'm trying to find his his argument with Ellie B. Kenny's
here to say food chops is winning. I know that is Kenny's uh
for some reason Kenny with these avatars that seemingly always
lining up in a certain direction wants to defend food. >> number
one problem. Number two, I am Nostradamus. I said F shuffle was
winning like what a few weeks ago in in this in a VC and look
what happened now. >> Do Do you remember Do you remember
what she Hold on. Do you remember what she you said she was winning
because of
>> Oh, okay. I'm just saying there's a there's a pattern
where people are just >> want to say it. >> Allegedly.
Alleged. Do you guys think I I'm moving? I think it's a joke.
I think she's But you know, Epstein files are not coming out.
you know, more lollycon viewtubers by the day. I mean, it's over.
It's over for kids. I mean, loss came too late. That's what I'm
saying. You just have to deal with it to take it
>> You sound like you're like laying on your tummy. You're
like hicking your feet right now, dude. >> Yeah, I am.
Just It's just over.
>> Let's go. >> Okay. Why are you lolly avatar? This
is This is just a big head. >> This This was like the thread
or whatever. Okay. This is the thread. >> Oh, it's got
click. very off topic. Okay, Destiny legitimately has some behavior
you need to apologize for. By the way, I'll give the same take
I did cuz it was my like reactionary take to this, right? But
I just I thought this thread was interesting. I was like, "Oh,
do you want to talk about this?" Cuz like it seemed like um seemed
like you made some weird claims that you would never make. Like
Dev is like a smart person and I'm like, "Dude, you you know
that you made like a totally claim here, right?" And I told him
like, "Hop on stream, we can talk about it." And then I covered
the stuff, but we'll just look >> How is Pixie using the
court in bad faith? Yeah, Pixie has clearly been using the court
system in bad faith, making untrue claims, using the process
to silence criticism. Neither of these wash away the other. Both
are true.
Uh Ellie asks, "What are you talking about?" Dev says, "I've
since looked over the whole case. Destiny is far from innocent,
but so is Pixie. Turns out she shared the tape with people behind
his back as well, last I checked. Plus, her actions in court
have been uh not great." And Ellie says, "Oh, so you just believe
the thing Destiny completely lied about. Whatever. Not worth
arguing with anyone who still takes his word as gospel. Let me
know if you ever break out of that. So again,
all he has to do here is show evidence of this, right? And I
would say, so I think my issue with this would be that Pixie
said she shared it with her uh boyfriend what on May 9th or something
like way before the PI hearing. And now Desi heard this in PI
hearing apparently had a vision from God that this was the big
leak. This is the big this is a big game changer.
Part of the documents for like weeks at that point, but whatever.
If you have proof he lied, I'd like to see it. How can So this
is basically Dev is making a positive claim. Yes, Pixie lied.
Pixie lied and she's been using this process to silence criticism.
So the the positive claim from Dev are these uh where is Dev's
evidence? I think that's what uh Ellie is going to ask for. Hey,
where's your evidence? He's like, well, if you have proof he
lied, it's like, dude, you realize you're taking the foundational
position that what Destiny said is true, and you're asking other
people to disprove it, right? You're you're just saying, "Well,
Destiny's word is true, and you need to disprove it." That's
not how making claims works, right? And that I laid that out
for him, and apparently pointing out that it's to just say Destiny
told the truth before seeing any evidence.
Apparently, that's giving him the shank, which I don't get it
at all. Did you tell him? Yeah, I literally messaged him and
said like, "Hey, if you want to hop on stream, dev's mad at you
for not gaslighting uh Ellie." Yeah, I don't know. You've proof
he lied. I'd like to see it. As I said, I've been looking over
everything I can get my hands on, whether it's Prodesty or Antie.
He and I are not friends. I'm just interested in the truth. But
he is without. So, where did you get the idea that she probably
that she shared it with people behind his back? Reading the KF
thread. I think I've archived everything I've seen for a future
video on the topic. If you have evidence that's wrong, send it
my way and I'll archive that, too. Okay. So, just produce it.
Why? Why are you arguing on Twitter when you could just say,
"Here's the evidence." He's literally saying, "Hey, I saved the
evidence." And she's like, "Wait, where? Oh, I saved it." Okay.
Could you show me it? Clearly didn't or originate in the KF thread.
I'm asking you what evidence you saw to support it. Uh, don't
fully recall, which is why I said the in the original tweet last
I checked. I I know I have it stuffed away somewhere, but I'm
open to being wrong. What do you have? Again, positive claim.
Could you just show me the evidence for what you're claiming?
Um, the funny thing here is is this is what she's basically asking
Dev, I She's telling Dev, I think you take Destiny's word as
gospel. I think you heard Destiny say this. I think you have
no source for this at all. That is like a like a third party
like sort of objective source. You heard Destiny say this and
you're repeating it. Which, by the way, possibly that could be
true. Very, there is a world where that's possible, right? But
dev is just believing what Pixie said. This dev person seems
like a dum dum. They're not. Which makes me think that this is
either like malicious and they won't talk about it. Like they
know how stupid they sound, which is why they wouldn't get on
stream to talk about it, but they're not a stupid person. This
is somebody I like actually like a lot of their political stuff
they've done on their channel. I don't think he's malicious.
I think he is. I think he understands that he said something
really dumb here and he doesn't have the evidence he said he
had and he looks he just looks stupid, right? But his his actual
political stuff that he's done is not bad
and it's it's very frustrating that he um is just pretending
to be
So then she >> uh Okay, go ahead. Go ahead. >> Oh,
what I have is a pretty big problem because I know where it came
from. a completely baseless claim from Destiny about an event
about his that his close friend claims he doesn't remember which
is counteracted by earlier court filings and his own words you
this is why I think it's important to maintain the expectation
that people who make affirmative claims against his victims should
be able to substantiate them because his strategy is clearly
to damage his victims to try to shut them up and other try try
to shut them and other victims up I will send you what I have
but it's untenable for Steven to be able to come out with a new
smear every day and the burden to be placed on his victims who
are in an impossible position regarding defending themselves
publicly to disprove them. They have replies, "Well, I don't
want anybody to shut up because of what I posted, and I don't
think that'll happen. I have no reach, but I'm willing to see
what you have. Thank you." No.
Right. Right. Like, she literally says, "Oh, it's insane to make
affirmative claims based on nothing, which I think you're she's
implying that's what you're doing." And Dev goes, "Well, I'm
happy to see what you have, huh?"
Yeah. Here's the thing, is he's not he has to know that this
is insane. He has to know that this is like complete him him
doing this and his dodging of anybody on streams is exactly how
you know he knows it's okay. >> Do you uh do remember when
um when I met Queman in the server and it was a argument about
dev? >> Was it an argument about dev? I thought it was
an arg No, it was a argument about Chuck Conroy, not Dev.
>> Uh well, I mean Dev was a big part of it. He made one
of the videos, right?
>> I was trying to argue about Dev. I think >> I
thought you were trying to argue about Chucky Conroy.
>> No, no, that Yeah, that was what the argument was about,
but it it trailed off because Dev made a video and I was like,
"This video is bad." It like really wasn't.
I don't remember that part. But what were you arguing, >> dude?
I don't I remember the argument happening. I don't remember my
position. I know I I took like a position that I I
>> I don't think your position was that I think Queen was
being a total in that debate. I I I think for dev specifically,
I because I remember this because this is going to be a part
of whatever video I was making at the time. I was going to try
to say like dev's being bad faith. Dev's like a I don't know,
something like that. Like dev is being bad faith and like lying
and
um the argument, the whole the whole thing was basically that
people were sweeping for Chucka Conroy. But I I think at this
point my mind's been changed. I think the big thing for me is
that it just happened like 15 years ago. So, I don't really think
it's sweeping. I I don't really remember what my exact position
was. It was a
>> had to have a position wasn't it was it was basically
just subjective. It was like a totally subjective thing
>> and yeah, I had to watch Queenman pull out every debate
trick in the book, the
It was very funny. I'm sorry that I just sat back and watched,
but it was uh it he he would I think he would admit that that
he was just like he was trying to
Yeah, it was weird. It was a weird debate. I remember that. Feel
like if he doesn't know bases of the Pixie situation, replying
in this indirect
>> She's not replying in a long-winded way. What What's
confusing here, Loki Coco?
How is it not incredibly >> like a little dude? I love
him. >> Wait, what are you confused about here? It's a
completely bas I think you got this from a completely basis claim
from Destiny. How about you actually back up your affirmative
claims?
How is that even confusing? What do you mean if they don't? Hold
on. This is exactly what she's getting at. I know where your
thought on this comes from. Completely baseless came from Destiny.
Yes. That's like That's what she's saying, right? Cuz he asked
what he got wrong.
No, he didn't ask what he got wrong. He asked if she could disprove
what he was saying.
But she knows that there's no proof to show that what he said
happened even happened. So, you're asking me to disprove something
where there's no evidence for it? How can I disprove something
that I don't even have evidence of happened? What? You asked
me to disprove something testimony in a sealed transcript that
I can't see? How? How could I possibly do that? I'm saying that
it's baseless. It's just Destiny's opinion. Anyway, sorry, sorry,
sorry, sorry. All these tweets don't come off as sassy almost
ever,
dude. I this Ellie person, by the way, everywhere where Ellie
replies to anybody around Destiny, Destiny comes in to their
replies, unblocks them, replies, "This Ellie person is mentally
ill. Beware and then blocks them again." >> Are you >> Who
is Ellie? Are they Who are they? Are they someone >> like
an anti- Redill person who doesn't like uh doesn't like Destiny
to me or sorry, doesn't like Destiny anymore. I read the to me
never replies. Seems that he never replies directly to me unless
I really trigger him because he knows I'll ask him questions
he can't answer. like why he's been unable to confirm his friend
Rose's age. Only replies to other gossip uh people who gossip
about me. Basically, I Dude, it's so crazy that people just do
this. It's like this person's crazy and then they don't contend
with anything they say.
It's so >> You got a YN in the waiting room, dude. You
might have a debate on your hands. Look at that. >> It's
I mean, you say that it's just going to be Kathy. Oh, it's Izzy
Mandas. Never mind. Izzy Mandius, what's up?
>> Not much, man. Okay. I I couldn't figure a better time
to make this happen. But uh so
there was that like update in the uh in the uh Pixie Destiny
case that's kind of been frying my brain a little bit and I was
actually in a thread with uh the le about this um and Destiny
hopped in um where uh Abby popped up um on Twitter and she had
just gotten out of like a stint in the uh >> Yeah, sure.
Sure. >> in the hospital, right? And he was like saying
like, "Oh, this is the the star witness on on Pixie's case."
And he's kind of smearing her. And I was like, "You're going
to give her the lab treatment, yada yada." Just threw a snipe
out like there like that. And he um it seems to be that this
was this the the this was the girl who was like in Destiny's
house apparently, like took a picture at >> Oh, I remember
your replies. Yeah. Yeah. >> Oh, I know. I remember. I
think I reviewed your tweet and was like, "Oh, you just don't
know a few of the facts
>> Yeah. And I I kind of look like a dumbass for it, but
that's fine. I would rather know than not know, but like
>> does that does that not kind of blow like a huge hole
in the pixie case? Am I like crazy here? Cuz like I talked to
Ellie about this afterwards and she kind of she kind of really
was not happy about me like, you know, having some reservations
here. But like that's a >> you can you can have reservations.
>> Uh she says so she says that she was sent these things.
She has like contempor contemporaneous evidence that on some
date in November she was talking about being sent these things
I think of 2023 right that she was sent these things in 2023
November 2023 I believe that's the date the timeline and she's
at Destiny's place I believe months before that maybe two months
before that and so it would be weird if she found this stuff
she was willing to to send to Darius and then she waited months
to tell Darius about it or anyone around him like that would
be the first thing that makes me think like apparently She was
just sending like texting things directly to Darius. Um,
>> what else? There's no evidence that she went through
anything on his computer. Like whatever's there, whatever's visible,
sure, but like would he have just had like all of his like open
and out on his computer or and then did he leave this person
with his computer for all of this time?
>> Like did he Yeah, >> cuz as far as I know, like
if you've got a bunch of like super sensitive [__]
on your computer, why would you be leaving your computer like
open with this person there? Well, Destiny's got a is a dumbass
and has a history of this. Remember the Denims situation where
she he she got left alone in his apartment with some other dude
that she and like he was like this was actually one of the biggest
like possible security leaks that I might have ever had. And
you know, he he apparently has a history of this, but like that's
not really an excuse, but you know, he could just be like, "Oh,
I was a dumbass." Which is probably going to be his defense.
But the other thing is like there's um it's >> it would
be weird for her to like sit on this stuff for you know >> Oh,
a year and a year and some change, right? Until November. >> She
messaged friends about it, right? >> Yeah. Well, yeah,
right. She didn't but um the leak >> like two months, not
not a year later, right? It was a So, she talked about it a year
before the leaks happened. Also, um, where would the pixie video
have been that it would apparently be at like the top of his
like would it be at the top of his drive or the top of his like
Where would she have found the pixie video there? Cuz they say,
"Oh, I think he says like, oh, the second person my Discord list
is Cherry." It's like, okay, let's say hypothetically that was
possible that it was like, "Oh, right there. She clicked into
that and saw it, right?" Say hypothetically that's possible.
Where did she learn about the Pixie video from? >> Right.
It had to had to have actually been sent to her is what you're
saying. Well, it would had to been sent to somebody or like
did he not check any of his [__] when he found out
this person was on his computer? You not check to see where his
like history went? Did he not like there should be so many things
that he could have gone and looked at that would have made things
make some kind of sense?
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, it's just uh >> when I uh started
hearing about that, I was like I started to get really um worried
for the Pixie for Pixie side in the case because it's like I
don't know how you make this work for a judge and like a jury
because uh the whole like the whole arguments about like oh is
it going to be at the top of the drive? I'm like I don't know
if it I don't know if this is going to come across how this is
going to come across to a judge or whatever. How do you like
argue? I think you would have to say, so basically, did you have
the Pixie video on like the your desktop or something, right?
>> Is that what you're claiming? You had it like sitting
on your desktop or some um like where did you have it that it
was such that it was like out for somebody to find? Cuz that's
what this whole case is about, right? The Pixie video. >> Um
and then I would just say, "What proof do you have?" Like beyond.
So she didn't know anything was getting leaked. When she thought
she could say anything to people, she said, "Oh, he sent me this,
right? He sent it via some link. So, she didn't know that there
was any case when she said this, right? She has these logs from
2023 or yeah, 2023 where she's saying this to people. Why would
she lie there? She'd already she'd already openly told Darius
she was at his computer. She'd already taken pictures of the
diary apparently shared them with Darius or something like apparently
Molina's diary or something. Why would she now lie about this,
>> right? Yeah, that's >> I actually don't know.
I mean, I I can't claim to know either. Um, >> so I would
just say that there's proof she knew about it. Um, there's proof
she was on Destiny's computer, but I don't have any reason to
think that she went through his computer personally or that she
went through or that like I I really have no reason to think
that he would have left her alone with his computer for that
long to tell you the truth. He says he did. I don't believe it.
I don't believe him, right?
>> Got a bunch of sensitive on his computer. I just don't
I don't believe that. But I mean, maybe somebody would believe
that. In any case, I see no reason to believe that she took something
off of his computer. Also, uh, if she mentions going through
his computer at all, shouldn't it be in those DMs? >> Why
wouldn't you just send send me that entire DM scroll, right?
>> Yeah, that should be everything. Yeah, Darius. Cuz like
it's like if uh somebody was arguing this like if she um if she
had sent stuff to Darius, then you know Darius would have it.
He would be able to produce proof of that. He would be able to
actually, you know, present that to Destiny. Destiny could present
that in court for sure. But she never did that. we get, you know,
this is kind of and I mean I know that this is a case that's
basically kind of built off of a lot of like whimsy like that
is kind of built off of some like screenings from a lot of different
like online services, but that does feel like even just the this
the two just like her in front of the computer and then saying
big leaks incoming can kind of be like flimsy connection that
she just the thing that she decided to leak had to have been
you know. >> Yeah. Oh, right. It says big leaks incoming.
If that means something, then show me the big leaks. >> If
that doesn't just mean I'm leaking like your his dashboard right
here, then show me the big leaks. Show me the rest of the DMs.
But he doesn't, right? Cuz that's as good as it gets.
>> Yeah, that's really that's really all it is. Um there
should be something there, especially because Darius is still
Destiny's boy, so it should be something. But yeah. >> Yeah.
Yeah. I covered this on stream when you went over it and I remember
that I think that's what I said is like if there's big leaks
incoming then show me the rest of the DMs where those big leaks
happen. If there's nothing else there then like okay then I I
don't believe you. I those are kind of my thoughts. But uh yeah,
I just I wanted to talk about that because I just I was completely
blindsided
by that and I if like I don't know that still worries me that
like the jury is going to see that like Abby is somebody who
like infiltrated Destiny's like not infiltrated but like was
in Destiny's home alone with his computer and like they might
just be like oh oh she's a crazy woman who like got it dug through
his computer and found his [__] and sent it to herself.
>> Why is he Hold on. Why would he let a crazy woman on
his computer to do all that [__] >> Well, why
would he leave her alone in there? I don't know. Like, I >> I
don't know. I just don't think um man, maybe in any case, I think
this um in any case, I think it survives summary judgment. And
honestly, if it comes down to if it comes down to if they don't
find anything via discovery and it comes down to what evidence
is there, including like this stuff, I think I don't think you
find Destiny guilty on those charges. Like I that would just
be my opinion, right? Like as it is. So if if you cannot find
actual evidence via the um the subpoenas that he sent the video
after the Cardi date, then I don't know that you can find him
guilty on um balance of probability.
But I don't I don't think that Aby's really changes that much
for me. It's just like well I don't actually have any evidence.
I have no no evidence that this has actually been transmitted
after the date. I only have innuendo. And unfortunately, like
I I just don't think even balance of probability wise I could
there's probably an argument. It'll come down to possibly a jury
if they go to trial, right? Where it's like, well, there's the
the contemporaneous evidence with um there's the contemporaneous
evidence, but also it just seems spooky. Sorry, there's a contemporaneous
evidence, but it seems spooky that she's like on the computer,
but also like just that
man, I don't know. It's so that a year beforehand she knows multiple
names that are not not leaked until way later. That's just that's
crazy to me. I I just >> Yeah. I don't know. >> Yeah.
Yeah. I >> It's not like she It's not like she was just
guessing and missed. Right.
>> Right. Yeah. That's kind of uh what hinders of >> Yo,
what's up, moral? >> What do you say to the admission of
guilt that he gave on like um >> Oh, yeah. the the cope
I've been getting from and I've
been a few group chats or like had a few DMs with pe with people
who are like really hardcore like they they claim to not watch
Destiny anymore, but they're definitely still DGers. Um who make
it seem as though the admission of guilt um is not so much an
admission of like, oh, I betrayed your trust in that I sent the
uh the DMs to uh that I sent the the or I sent these this explicit
content to other people. The admission the admission of guilt
was about the fact that like there was obviously a breach in
like some in in his um computer or like somehow somebody got
into his and it meant that like he
>> but but he doesn't but no no he he signed an affidavit
that says I sent it to this person with the with and the affidavit
like I believe doesn't say non-conensual. believe it's he says
with implied consent like I I thought I could send it to this
person which makes this statement not make any sense. If he sent
it and he admits sending it with what he believes was Pixie's
consent, right? Then hey [__] lol. I know I violated
your trust in the worst way ever, but here's some money. Have
fun. That makes no sense, right? So he's just lying. He's like
transparently lying. This totally contradicts everything. This
was him being this was him when he thought he could contain it,
right? He's not saying he's not saying this because um he's like
he's not saying it because of
>> Unfortunately, like he's just going to say, "Well, actually
now I'm under oath and now I have to tell the truth." But
>> you're telling the truth here when you thought this
stuff wouldn't get leaked anywhere. Obviously,
>> that's the problem. Like there this court case has got
so many like it's gotten ropey enough and it's been going on
long enough that there's enough like that it's all gets a little
jumbled. But the admission of guilt is is what made me just be
like, "Well, that's it then, isn't it?" like this guy, you know,
8 n months ago when this first all kind of went down. >> Um
but the the the the cope that I got immediately after that thread
like that cuz Destiny hopped in so it caught a lot of DGG eyes
obviously. um was just like they were they would say to me uh
the admission of guilt was just about like him feeling bad that
somehow he allowed his OPSAC to get bad enough that like somebody
was able to gain access to his uh to his explicit content and
that that was the violation of trust which seems like a load
of horses but >> yeah I mean he's literally signed a sworn
statement that says I mean if he pen statement under penalty
of perjury okay that says I sent it to this person.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's um it's really really stupid. A lot
of this again Yeah. I know it's probably annoying to like rehash
some of this older stuff, but it's like Yeah. It's just hard
to keep a lot of it straight in my head. And I have like have
like several like I'm arguing like fighting from my life dealing
with like DGs who are just sort of like have all his arguments
down path. >> I assume they're your friends. They could
always just call in and I I could be I could be very gentle with
people. Okay, they always just call in. It's like no problem.
>> They don't even want me in here. They don't even want
me talking to you. I was saying like, "Huh, this is an interesting
thought that I hadn't, you know, considered. I was going to maybe
I should talk to Jay talk about it and, you know, we can we can
kind of hash it out. I wanted to been wanting to do this for
several nights and they're like, "No, man. Don't even bother
giving him the content. It's just going to get you like docks
and it's just going to get they're just going to you're going
to end up on Kiwi Farms, bro. You're I'm like, what do you think
these people are?" Like they basically they talk about you as
if you're a snark community. Like snarking. You know how that's
become like a like a slur now? >> Yeah. Like this is like
they treat you as a snark community. They treat you as the kind
of community like the same people who sent skulls to to Ethan
Klein's front porch. That's the way that a lot of these guys
who defend Destiny. They literally said that. They literally
think that you're that you're that type >> I just think
Sure. Sure. Sure. Like a key part of like the the being like,
"Oh, these snarkers are so crazy." A key part of this is taking
all negative actions that's ever happened to the person who's
like the object of derision like Ethan. All bad things that have
ever happened to him and trying to assign all blame to everybody
in that. It's like a Rico case, right? If anybody does something,
everybody else who's like even remotely negative of Ethan is
responsible for that. Denim's sent the skulls. Denim's called
CPS. Froen called CPS. Froen sent the skulls. They're all They're
all responsible, right? they all contribute to the environment
and so they're all responsible in the same ways and that's obviously
right and that's just anybody who tries to undertake that narrative,
anybody who tries to project that narrative is only trying to
silence criticism. They're mad that people are criticizing them
and so they're trying to lump in the crazy people who are criticizing
them with the normal people who are criticizing them. Um, Pirate
Software did this, right? Pirate Software constantly showed his
messages from people who are like, "Oh, I I think you should
be scared to go outside." And he's like, "This is why you can't
come in my chat and say manage." Okay, you say manage them in
my chat. You feel people like this? It's like, no, they don't.
That's insane. These are entirely separate groups of people.
There's no evidence that they coordinate in any way whatsoever
other than they have one shared attribute. It's like they think
you're annoying or they think you're a [__] degenerate
loser. They think you're a degenerate loser like predator in
the case of Destiny, right? That's that's the only connection
that exists here. So, it's it's so yeah, it's just so insane
to me because like it's first off, it's the webbing technique
that Destiny literally highlighted that Hassan does to other
people and he's doing it now. you pointed that out before and
like I the when I ask them like um and I think I talked about
this in your chat like I don't a couple nights ago or something
about like the claim that like somehow you are showing like Kiwi
his Kiwi Farm on the stream and that you're like somehow leading
people to his Kiwi Farms thread where not only his docs is at
but a bunch of his friends's docs is at and his explicit content
and Pixie's explicit content and Cher's explicit content is.
And I'm like, what what is the what is the proof of that? Like
where is it? And the response is always just, dude, they have
made a giant hate community against him. Like, can you really
not understand? And this is like, can you really not understand
what like see how they would be leading people to the Kiwi Farms
thread? And I'm like, that's not proof. And it was and I was
like flabbergasted because food shops employed the exact same
arguments. They literally all have the exact same marching orders.
You have a community that hates him, so you must be leading them
to the Kiwi Farms thread somehow. They literally go so far as
to explicitly claim that you are just showing his Kiwi Farms
willy-nilly on stream or whatever or just like Yeah. leading
people to it despite not having any proof of it. And it's like
h literally just because you guys have like you and Queen. >> But
in particular, >> the funny thing is >> Yeah. Mhm.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, the funny thing is is um Destiny,
Willie Mack, these people actually do the things that they say,
right? They actually show the Kiwi Farms page, show have find
the uh either the the sexual content or like the non-consensual
sexual content or they find ways to show like um or or they're
driving people towards Yeah. like docs of his friends and [__]
Destiny does this all the time. Destiny loves to do this. It's
a called negative polarization. Okay. We call we call this you're
trying to negatively polarize people back towards you. So essentially,
if I if you get in Destiny's mind, if you get Docs in that thread
and you're one of his friends, he's going to tell you about he's
going to tell you these people are attacking you, right? Because
he wants you to be drawn closer to him. This is almost certainly
why he went after Willie Mack the way he did. Okay? Sorry, not
went after, why he continues to like undercut Willie Mack. He's
going to make Willie Mack look even more to his commentary friends
so that Willie Mac's only bridge, only connection to anybody
professionally will be destiny, right? That's why he goes and
every the criticisms of Willy Mack that he's really sherking
against that he's really upset about is you just you're just
a Destiny suck. You're a Destiny Dick rider, right? And what
choice does he have but to be a Destiny rider when Destiny opens
up his video and goes, "Oh, uh yeah, I sent vid I sent Willie
proof of this and like I gave him the exact narrative that he's
doing right now." Yeah. Like I told him this exactly. It's like
the exact here's what I damned him. And he said reads off like
Willy's exact thesis for why people are doxing him, right? >> Yep.
Yeah, >> that's Destiny saying, "I gave you your narrative."
Exactly. >> And he understands that that is a totally cutting
Willy's legs out in his current community, right?
>> Because the only place he'll have to stand up after
that is the DG community. >> Yeah. It's really It's actually
kind of a little gross to see. And it's like it's like guys like
Nick Dioro. No hate towards him to be fair, but like >> no
towards that fat.
>> Sorry. Sorry. Go ahead. >> No, I get it. I get
it. I understand. I understand. Um Yeah. I know. He's like he
he hasn't he hasn't spoken up on this for a reason or has dedicated
what was it like 6 to 10 minutes of one stream to it is because
he he sees this. He knows this. He's not a I know you hate him
morale but he's not a stupid guy. He >> No, he's not he
knows he's not stupid. He knows what he's doing. I just think
what he's doing is cowardly. >> Yeah, it is. I think I
think it really is. Um >> he 10,000% understands what is
going on with Destiny and Willie. He is trying to stay out of
it as to not
whatever his money machine is, which right now is >> like
the eth. >> Can I ask you? Can I ask you moral? Why why
is nobody tweeted? I just explained to you what what Destiny's
doing with Willie. Why is nobody tweeting the clips of this?
I didn't get a chance to do it. I'm on I'm not on Twitter that
often and my super astroturf by DGers, but like it's really obvious
that Destiny just gave like basically wants people to he This
is the thing. Destiny wants us to make a big deal out of it.
But also, we should make a big deal out of it. Unfortunately,
we have to do the exact thing that uh he's trying to do as well,
right? Because unfortunately, >> if I were Destiny and
I saw you or other people around you tweeting out clips, I would
probably say all these people are like schizophrenic. Like, why
would you even bother listening on like they're conspiratorial
losers? Obviously, I'm going to tell Willie like if he gets doxed,
like that's insane. Obviously, I'm going to try to protect this
guy even if he's, you know, critical or whatever. He'd probably
just do like plausible deniability stuff like that, I would assume.
>> Well, and also think about this is this is like a a
big part of like Destiny's strategy and has been for a while.
like um he if you draw the eye of DGG like it's a like I'm sorry
but Ellie B to this day anything she said like you said any time
she comments anything like like especially if she replies to
Destiny she has DGG on her
like constantly even for stuff that is completely unrelated to
him like she like it it's it's there's no there's no almost no
positive to having to to speaking out and then ending up with
a bunch of those in your
up your like reply section and like blowing up your notifications
and it's like it's just it's not something that it's not a good
feeling. I can't necessarily blame anybody for not wanting to
like speak up or speak out like it would be the right thing to
do but like and it's the sort of the same reason it kind of to
broaden things here. It's like it's kind of the same thing that
I think is kind of happening with all the leaks that have happened
with like explicit content. Like like a lot of these women probably
full well know that Destiny has like leaked their or has leaked
to um to them that they know is not consensual like was or was
shared non-consensually. But like if they speak out about it,
they're going to end up getting the treatment that like Abby
is now getting and that Pixie is now getting. Like they don't
want to do this. And it used to just be Destiny would, you know,
Destiny's community would be on someone's ass that when he disagreed
with them and then like they they had talked about Destiny, that
was fine because like whatever. You came at a big creator, you
kicked the hornets's nest, now you have a bunch of DJers kind
of up your replies, whatever. But now it's like literally harassment
and intimidation to keep people silent about things that people
should be speaking up about. And that's kind of sickening. >> Yeah,
it's pretty unfortunate.
>> It's pretty up. Anyways, I just Yeah. Um, this guy kind
of like he kind of grosses me out now. It's really funny that
he can have a grandstand about somebody else looking at his kiwi
farms when he's literally looking at it to the tune of like thousands
of viewers. Like, you're not not really any better. But anyways,
I should uh get out of you guys' hair, but it was I'm glad I
got to talk to you all about it. >> Yeah, it's just goofy.
But yeah, thanks for coming on. Uh, by the way, just tell your
tell your friends like this literally not true and they could
just hop on whenever they want.
>> I'll tell them the milk. They probably never will because
they just they they see they they I can't I cannot overstate
the hatred they have for you. They do not they see that you as
somebody that like that they feed content to or whatever, it
would be like it's just like a terrible thing. They see you as
just like Yeah, it's it's wild to me. like you've become like
a a pariah to them in like the in like the wildest >> I
think so like that's
pretty much like how a cult would function, right? I understand
that they like I that's basically what it's come down to is they've
identified that speaking to anybody with like an IQ above room
temperature makes them look stupid and so outside opinion is
to be like issued
>> Yeah. I mean food shops realized it pretty quickly,
right? like she had two backto-back debates with two people who
like who like can actually function in a conversation and actually
think through these things and she looked like a both of them.
I don't fully I fully believe that like after the second debate
she pro Destiny probably hopped in her in her DMs and was like
okay listen
you need to let either me or somebody else handle these conversations.
You're not you're not a >> I don't think so. I don't think
I don't think you'd be caught dead like DMing somebody what to
do right. I don't think you'd be caught in doing that. Um, >> I
don't believe that. I think Food Chops is dumb enough to debate
and look stupid in a debate if Food Chops is smart enough to
uh to realize when they're in a losing battle and to stop, >> right?
Yeah. No, I I hear that. Yeah, that's a good point. Um, yeah,
it just it was just so those were just so too just like back
to back unbelievable.
I like I could not believe what I was watching. Like it actually
really was just like to hear to hear somebody so like clearly
and lay out just like well yeah if he's mad enough at you he's
he's going to dox you like if you're if you're ping him off enough
he's going to dox you and I'm like what you're >> just
pointed this out tonight too that like that's not the argument
at all. That's like not what anybody should be talking about.
It's like okay what should the penalty be for him not being able
to control his emotions? Like what is the moral wrong? Like how
severe is the moral wrong and why is it morally wrong? Nobody
nobody's care nobody cares. Like right
there's like there are other examples of this, right? Like if
you yell the hard R in a room full of black people, I would expect
you to potentially face like some uh physical consequences for
that, right? In a room full of people, you just have no respect.
You you scream that word out. It's possible you get hit or something,
right? I could expect that. Doesn't make it okay for you to get
hit, right? Doesn't make it okay for somebody to to punch you
in the face or something.
Um, like it's it's
Yeah, it's like that, right? It it doesn't matter. I Well, sorry.
It's like that in that that's a more extreme example,
>> Shut up, Baba. >> Um, that's a more extreme example,
but like it's it doesn't matter if somebody's like if somebody's
just talking, you have the right to like actually try to hurt
them. >> Yeah. Yeah, for sure. And I think it became more
like the the bias became more like nakedly obvious when you got
work around towards like Keles, which food chops I think is the
one who brought up first anyways. Um but it just makes it more
clear like she like the only real difference there is that Kiwi
Farms was, you know, being pinned on Destiny, you know, and now
K being it's now it's no longer like Kel's the one who's pointing
at Kiwi Farms pointing at people who use Kiwi Farms. It's Destiny.
like there's really no difference there. It's just that the the
mind virus is just like so yeah, I don't know. It was really
black pilling to watch. It was pretty up. But I don't know. >> Yeah,
there's uh there's some other interesting stuff pieces evidence
there, but I'm I'm uh I'm trying not to do quite as much of this.
Obviously, the food shop stuff and the doxing stuff. Like I'd
love to do content on it. It's just um >> trying to like
diversify a lot right now. trying to do some of the Ice Poseidon
community stuff and >> bounce around trying to do like
diverse >> Yeah. No, it's it's a thing you can it's a thing
that you've already done the content loop on that. I totally
feel you. But uh yeah, thanks for talking guys. Uh >> no
problem. Appreciate it. >> Thanks for coming on. Uh I would
really love to talk to your friends though. Like literally like
borderline that I would almost consider doing it offline, but
like I don't know. I just like, dude, I I feel like so many people
are like I feel like they know they're totally in the wrong.
>> If they join the Discord, you'll do it offline about
it. >> Yeah. I mean, we could just we could just do it
in uh like a Discord call. I would love to do it with people
in just like a Discord call again. >> Yeah, I'd uh Yeah,
I'll see what I can do. I can think of I can probably think of
at least one who would who I could probably like convince have
this conversation because she she argues so uh vehemently in
uh against me like or pro in favor of Destiny really um or really
against like the people who go after him which is just how they
mask being like GDG people but yeah um yeah
>> okay anyways uh yeah it was good talking guys y'all
have a good rest of the >> yeah you too well I actually
think we're uh we're technically I love the stream here. So,
I think we're going to sign off after this.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Okay. Well, it was a good stream.
So, uh yeah, man. Y'all take it easy. >> Loved it. >> Nice
night, chats. See you later. Later, Kenny. Y'all take it easy.
>> Good night. >> See you. What else we got here?
I think I'm going to cover the Roblox stuff tomorrow probably.
See what we got online. Nobody online. I was about to search
for Queen.
I realized he raided me. So, GG, guys. GG.
>> That's tough. >> Yeah. Hate food shops. Oh, nah.
No, no, no.
I don't think so. Raid Lety Vision. Lety Vision. >> Ridier
god. >> Wait, is there somebody better in uh Scavenger
Hunt? Who I want to raid? Who are we watching? >> It's
M.
>> I'm raiding Tamman. I'm not raiding Letty. I'm raiding
Tamman. Okay, guys. I'm rating Tamman. Uh I love you guys and
I'll be back tomorrow. Okay. Thanks for covering the ice drama.
Yeah, no problem, man. Thanks for showing up tonight, guys. We'll
be back tomorrow. Okay, have a good night. Bye-bye. Bye. Bye.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. by